this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream get free access to
nebula
the streaming platform built by all your
favorite youtubers when you sign up for
curiosity stream at the link below
[Music]
we live in a world dominated by the
economic system known as capitalism
private ownership of the means of
production is the norm giant
multinational corporations have a
greater gdp than entire countries
and we're currently witnessing the birth
of a second gilded age
complete with modern day robber barons
and skyrocketing inequality and poverty
for the first time in a hundred years
the united states is seeing a real
resurgence in class consciousness and
criticism of the status quo
we've seen record numbers of protests
and rallies low-wage workers are walking
out and demanding better conditions and
the language of class struggle is
finally beginning to seep back into the
american consciousness
it would be absurd to look around and
assert that everything is fine
that capitalism is providing a good life
and opportunities for the average
person when every quality of life metric
is in decline for everyone except the
top few percent
and yet as always there are those who
are unwilling to acknowledge the reality
of the situation
and instead fall back on ignorant or bad
faith arguments to defend a failing
economic system
in this episode we're going to look at
one argument in particular
the claim that without capitalism there
would be no innovation
let's start with the assertion itself
without capitalism there would be no
innovation
what does this imply it suggests that
the sole motivating factor for anyone to
do anything
is money the profit motive it suggests
that the only reason society has
advanced is because of capitalism
this is quite the claim and as we'll see
shortly
it is incorrect in both regards let's
start with the first point
the profit motive as the motivating
factor once upon a time
people produced food not to sell but to
consume themselves and stockpile for the
future
no money exchanged hands the end of
course this is an overly simplistic
argument
but people who make claims about the
efficacy of the profit motive should
remember that capitalism is a fairly
recent development in the grand scheme
of things
but leaving thousands of years of human
history aside even in the modern
capitalist era
there have been countless examples of
people choosing to innovate not because
they lusted after money
but because it was the right thing to do
one of the more well-known examples is
jonas salk
though it was declared eradicated in the
americas in 1994
polio was once a major threat to
children around the world
polio is an infectious disease that
attacks the central nervous system
and often leads to paralysis during the
first half of the 20th century what
began as localized polio outbreaks had
reached epidemic levels in north america
europe australia and new zealand and in
1952
the u.s faced the worst outbreak it had
ever experienced
infecting at least 58 000 people killing
3145
and leaving over 21 000 more with
varying degrees of paralysis in a single
year
some of the worst affected could no
longer breathe by themselves
and needed to be placed in what was
called an iron lung
this horrible disease brought
unspeakable suffering to children around
the world
but thanks to a team of innovative
scientists led by dr jonas salk
today polio is little more than a bad
memory
starting in 1948 dr sulk dedicated the
next seven years of his life to
understanding how polio worked and how
he could fight it
in 1955 when the news of salk's new and
effective vaccine was made public
he was hailed as a hero and a miracle
worker sulk became a household name
he could have taken advantage of this
newfound fame and made a fortune on the
vaccine
but he refused to patent his creation
who owns the patent on this vaccine
well the people i would say there is no
pat
this is could you patent the sun
jonas salk chose not to patent the
vaccine in order to maximize its
availability around the world
by 1959 90 countries were making use of
the polio vaccine
and by 1994 the disease had been
completely eradicated in north america
when people first learn about jonas salk
many of them are shocked that he chose
not to profit from his creation
it's an understandable reaction when the
norm in the pharmaceutical industry is
criminal price gouging
where executives rake in tens or even
hundreds of millions of dollars every
year
but if people like jonas salt can exist
in even the most lucrative fields
then the profit motive is not the only
motivating factor that exists
and this is only one example if you look
around you'll find many more
those who benefit from capitalist
exploitation will try to convince you
that people won't be motivated to
improve the world without a financial
incentive
but that's just not the case but enough
about this first point
let's move on to the second one the
claim that society has only advanced
because of the profit motive
capitalist apologists have a tendency to
view the private sector as some godlike
entity that operates with a hundred
percent efficiency
is the sole driver of innovation and
always acts in the best interest of the
people
this is rarely if ever the case in fact
the private sector hardly ever drives
innovation at all
take the iphone for example fans of
capitalism love to say things like uh
you tweet about socialism from your
iphone but you wouldn't have that iphone
without capitalism
that's a little disingenuous to say the
least if you look at the iphone
or just about any modern phone really
you'll see that very
nearly every critical part was developed
with public funding
microchips gps accelerometers image
sensors touch screens
these were all projects funded by the
public either via the government or the
military
and it's not just phone components
nearly every aspect of modern day life
was funded and created not by the
private sector
but by the public sector satellites the
internet
public schools national parks waste
management water infrastructure
things we rely on and take for granted
today are the result not of the supposed
capitalist innovation
but of public programs the private
sector rarely drives innovation
even the internet's favorite faux
futurist elon musk is only able to
pursue his vanity projects because of
billions of dollars of government
funding
okay so if capitalism isn't driven by
innovation
what is the driving factor it's pretty
simple really
capitalism is driven by the profit
motive not by some innate drive to
innovate
if something is profitable it will be
produced which leads to the
proliferation of cheap useless garbage
like 30 different kinds of poop emoji
pool floats and tens of thousands of
copycat phone cases
if we take the pharmaceutical industry
again instead of prioritizing new
critically important medicine the profit
motive incentivizes the production of
slight variations of existing drugs in
order to extend their patents
in this way capitalism actually prevents
innovation
by demanding that funding be allocated
towards the most profitable ventures
not the ones that will do the most good
or drive humanity forward
but this isn't the case everywhere if we
take a country like cuba
where healthcare is nationalized we see
a completely different approach
since they're not beholden to the profit
motive cuba has made astounding medical
advances even with a drastically lower
gdp than the us
not to mention decades of crippling u.s
sanctions
cuban doctors are renowned the world
over and during the pandemic
they not only easily handled their own
outbreak they also sent their doctors
and medical supplies to countries who
needed the most
all without the expectation of any kind
of profit
again capitalism will not produce
results unless there is a profit to be
made
because of this hundreds of thousands of
americans continue to suffer
while countries like cuba make
accommodations for humanitarian crises
with no expectation of profit but let's
move on to something a little more
current
i'm sure most of you have seen the viral
pictures of these signs put up at fast
food restaurants and other low-wage
businesses
workers have finally realized that they
have some bargaining power
at least for the time being if you're
unfamiliar with the situation
here's a brief synopsis low wage workers
are quitting or not coming back to work
because they can make more money on
unemployment
this has led to a number of managers
putting out signs saying that no one
wants to work anymore and suggesting
it's some kind of moral failing
here's the thing i don't know a single
person who would want to work a low-wage
miserable fast food job
the idea that people would want to toil
their life away dealing with awful
customers and doing thankless work is
absurd
this supposed american value of working
for work's sake
is a myth it's nothing more than
propaganda by those who own the
businesses
think about it if you were offered the
opportunity to not spend 10 hours a day
slaving over a grill or staring blankly
at spreadsheets and still make enough
money to live
would you take it of course you would
you could spend that time doing work you
actually enjoy
or finding a job that pays better that's
the thing capitalists never mention
most humans do have an inclination to
work they just don't want to work for
you
there's a difference between work being
productive with your time and skills
and the modern american conception of
work tedious labor people are obligated
to accept for fear of starvation and
poverty
now this trend of people refusing to
work low-wage jobs is a prime
opportunity for capitalists to innovate
they could come up with a way to make
their jobs more enticing to would-be
workers
have they done that no in fact they've
already run to the government to beg
them to fix their problem for them and
because all american administrations are
increasingly corporatized
we've gotten this a threat that if
anyone refuses a job offer
no matter how demeaning degrading and
miserable no matter how low the wages
they will be kicked off unemployment so
much for at will employment
capitalists can't stand the thought of
workers having any bargaining power
and so like with everything they demand
help from the government
capitalism doesn't innovate it only
pursues the next fistful of dollars
it asks where is there a profit to be
made it never considers the use value of
what it produces
only the profits it can make and so we
continue to receive mountains of cheap
products that will fail in a few months
the profit motive is not the driver of
innovation
it stifles innovation it prevents funds
from being used in a way that would
actually benefit the world
instead funneling that money into
pointless often incredibly destructive
projects
when there is innovation in america it
is in spite of capitalism
not because of it it's because people
like jonas salk realize that some things
are more important than profit
the claim that there would be no
innovation without capitalism is
blatantly false
it's disproven by history it's disproven
by other countries
it's disproven by common sense and more
and more often
it's disproven by the behavior and
actions of the capitalists themselves
if we really care about innovation we
need to dismantle capitalism and
throw the profit motive in the trash
where it belongs
if you'd like to learn more about how
capitalism has innovated all the joy out
of work
i highly recommend you check out
happiness at work on curiositystream
it's a fascinating look at just how
depressing the modern job really is
and how it got that way curiosity stream
is an established streaming platform
with a solid track record of caring
about great educational content
and the financial security of those who
produce it they've got thousands of
non-fiction titles from some of the best
filmmakers in the game
as you probably know youtube doesn't
treat its creators very well
that's why some of my youtuber friends
and i teamed up to build nebula
so we don't have to worry about
demonetization as
educational creators ourselves we love
curiositystream
so we've worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiositystream at the link
below
you'll also get access to nebula 100
free that's less than 15 bucks a year
for both curiosity stream and nebula
which in my humble opinion is a pretty
great deal since most of us are still
waiting for the vaccine
why not spend some time learning about
fascinating topics on curiosity stream
or check out nebula's original content
including my upcoming series on the
resurgence of fascism
you can also watch all my videos as they
were intended ad free
there really is something for everyone
and by signing up at the link below
you're helping us produce more content
without the fear of demonetization
give curiosity stream a shot and get
free access to nebula when you sign up
using the link below
it really does help support my channel
and educational creators all across
youtube
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes
if you hated it go ahead and drop a
thumbs down you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week